Bill Clinton George W bush and yes even
Barack Obama
yeah
um say that they don't have any
classified documents now of course this
is in response to the fact that Donald
Trump was found hiding hundreds of
classified documents Joe Biden and Mike
Pence had a small number of classified
documents and there are multiple stories
here as I've been covering on my podcast
and YouTube channel one of the stories
is the hypocrisy from the right Wingers
what Joe Biden did is terrible but what
Pence did and what Trump did are no big
deal that's one story that we've been
covering Second Story is there over
classification of documents in the
United States many National Security
Experts say yes too many things are
classified in the U.S that's a different
question than what whether any of these
individuals did is legal and then the
third story is is this much more common
than we might think